I got a rejection story that that ties
directly to you kind of okay
um and and it really also is
it's the it's the like fork in the road
moment where I went from like
actor pilot season act you know
traditional straight you know to
comedian and the last thing that I
tested for before I got mad tv was
Smallville I went to the studio for Pete
are you serious yeah yeah because I was
also repped by Tolan Robbins for
management wow so like they were heavily
involved in that obviously and and and
went there and then yeah they and then
they changed changed the casting Dynamic
for those roles yeah
um but yeah so like that was I you know
that's a crazy small world we could have
been working together yeah we could have
had seven years together I know I know
actually Pete left I think after two or
three years okay they let him go had
enough yeah well I think that the
character I didn't think they were going
anywhere with the character sure you can
only go like oh my
we make fun but we don't because with
Sam Jones who played Pete was was great
and we love him but uh there's an
episode in season one because we're
doing a re-watch show Tom and I yeah
yeah and we watch them and we critique
him but there's a scene where he sees a
dead body fall out of the closet yeah
he's like and his response for some
reason was
damn
who's that
I was like what
was that yeah I mean like that's what
you do when a body falls that's what I
didn't do in the audition that's why I
was rejected